legal eagle is coming in loud and clear
thanks to ting mobile
the president has been diagnosed with
covet 19 and has been flown to walter
reed medical center
his condition may be worsening this has
huge implications for not just the way
that the government is run
but also the 2020 election now we all
know that president trump mocked hillary
clinton's pneumonia
she's supposed to fight all of these
different things
and she can't make it 15 feet to her car
give me a break
made fun of biden for allegedly hiding
from the coronavirus in his basement
joe biden is sleeping or whatever he's
doing in his basement he doesn't seem to
come out a lot
and made fun of biden for wearing a mask
did you ever see a man that likes a mask
as much as him and made fun of biden
wearing a mask again
i don't wear mess like him every time
you see him he's got a mask he could be
speaking
200 feet away from it he shows up with
the biggest mask i've ever seen
so let me acknowledge the elephant in
the room there may be some schadenfreude
today from people who are gleeful about
this development i'm not one of those
people
copit19 is a serious apolitical virus
that isn't selective about who it
infects
and i wouldn't wish it on anyone many
people who work in the white house or
congress or attended fundraisers or
debates with the trump staff
were also exposed and we should hope
that they all recover with no
complications
however this is truly unprecedented for
many different reasons first of all
the major presidential candidates both
are over the age of 70. joe biden and
donald trump are both in the high risk
category for health complications from
covid19 and it would be irresponsible
not to consider what happens not only to
the
campaigns but also the country as a
whole if either of them
dies or becomes incapacitated especially
since president trump was diagnosed with
coronavirus just 33 days before the
election
how will american democracy handle this
earth-shattering event what if the
president is incapacitated or worse
before the election and what happens
between the election and the electoral
college
[Music]
hey legal eagles it's time to think like
a lawyer and a doctor
the president has coronavirus and all
four candidates for president and vice
president are mixing and mingling with
the american people during a pandemic
how panicked should we be about
something happening to one of them well
we have to start with the 25th
amendment the us constitution's original
plan for what happens in the event of a
presidential disability or inability to
work was for the vice president to take
over
this seems simple enough but article 2
section 1 clause 6
doesn't exactly explain how to decide
when a president is disabled or unable
to perform the duties of the office
congress passed laws to clarify the
procedure but nothing was formalized
until the 25th amendment was ratified in
1967.
so let's talk about section 3. section 3
of the 25th amendment provides the
president with the authority to declare
him or herself
unable to discharge the powers and
duties of the office if the president
makes a declaration this officially
transfers authority of the office to the
vice president who exercises it as the
acting president until the president
reclaims this authority by declaring the
disability to be ended
this could apply if the president was
having surgery for example
the key aspect of section 3 is that the
president has discretion over
when it applies and when it ends this
has happened a couple times before
ronald reagan sent a letter suggesting
that he was invoking section 3 when he
underwent surgery for apollo
george h.w bush was the acting president
for about eight hours after which reagan
resumed duties
when george w bush was president he
formally invoked section three twice
when he was anesthetized for routine
medical procedures
as vice president dick cheney took over
on both occasions
so hypothetically let's say president
trump declares that he will be unable to
perform the duties of his office during
his coronavirus quarantine
we know mike pence would be acting
present but there's one additional
wrinkle to consider
most scholars believe that he would not
be allowed to continue in his role as
president of the senate
according to the constitution the senate
shall choose their other officers
and also a president pro-tem poor in the
absence of the vice president or
when he shall exercise the office of
president of the united states
under such a scenario the president
pro-tempore would exercise the powers
and duties as the president of the
senate for the duration of disability
the vice president would resume both the
title and duties of president of the
senate once the president declared his
disability
over which brings us to section 4 of the
25th amendment which
is far more complicated you've probably
seen resistance twitter kicking around
the idea that the president's cabinet
invoking the 25th amendment because the
alleged trump is in the
mental decline there is in fact a
process for that but it's never happened
and it's highly political and
unlikely to happen section 4 provides
for instances of contingent presidential
disability this means that
there may be situations where a
president is unable to discharge the
duties of office
but is unwilling or unable to declare
the disability under section 3.
so if the president was suddenly taken
ill or put on a ventilator or had an
emergency surgery or went into a coma
then the 25th amendment applies because
the president wouldn't have the ability
to make that determination
for themselves however the authors of
the amendment also wanted to cover
scenarios where the president thinks he
or she is totally fine
but the vice president and a majority of
the cabinet think that he or she is not
fine
remember america is the country that was
created in part because colonists didn't
want to be ruled by king george iii
who was said to be suffering from
madness so
if the president is unwilling to declare
themselves
incapacitated then the cabinet and vice
president may
act under these circumstances the this
section authorizes the vice president in
a majority of either the cabinet
or any other body established by law
acting jointly to declare the president
to be disabled
the vice president would need the
concurrence of at least eight of the 15
cabinet officers to activate the
declaration of presidential disability
now once they notify the president
pro-tem and the speaker the vice
president immediately assumes the powers
and duties of the office as acting
president
now the drafters of the amendment were
well aware that this opened up the
possibility of a president being removed
solely for political reasons
therefore the amendment gives the
president a way back in
if the president in a time of his choice
transmits a written message to the
president pro-tem and the speaker that
no disability exists
he or she resumes office this sets up a
political showdown because the vice
president and majority of the cabinet
have four days to contest this finding
if they think the president is incapable
of serving and then
congress decides if a two-thirds vote of
both houses believe that the president
is unable to discharge the duties of
office the vice president continues as
acting president until the disability is
resolved
if a two-thirds margin is not obtained
or if congress is in session
but at the time does not vote on the
question within 21 days of receiving the
declaration then the president resumes
the powers and duties of office
similarly if congress is not in session
at the time and assembles but doesn't
vote within 21 days then the president
resumes the powers and duties of the
office
like i said this is complicated and
section 4 has not been activated since
the amendment was ratified in 1967
but there are two events during reagan's
presidency where it arguably should have
been
invoked on march 30th 1981 president
reagan was shot and seriously wounded
while leaving a speaking engagement in
washington
actually just down the street at the
hilton on connecticut he had an
emergency surgery and he was under
anesthesia
his aides debated whether or not to
invoke section four they were notified
that a full recovery was expected and
decided no further action
needed to be taken when president reagan
was shot al haig his secretary of state
made the big mistake of telling the
press that he was in control while the
president was in surgery
as of now i am in control here in the
white house
pending return of the vice president and
in close touch with him
if something came up i would check with
him of course this was considered a faux
pas demonstrating ignorance of the
constitution by a high-ranking official
which made the government look
particularly bad and although people
remember al haig's comment
few people are even aware that the other
side of section 4 was also in play
during
his presidency reagan's mental status
was also questioned by staff when he was
in office
in 1987 former senator howard baker
president reagan's newly appointed chief
of staff reportedly received a
memorandum from an aide
that claimed the president was
inattentive and inept the memorandum
went on to
urge baker to consider the possibility
that section 4 of the 25th amendment
might be applied
baker concluded the president was
attentive and alert and at a march 2nd
meeting
dismissed the report five years after
president reagan left the presidency he
was diagnosed with alzheimer's and we
don't know definitively whether he
suffered from the disease while he was
in office
but what happens to the presidency in
the line of succession is pretty simple
in comparison to what happens if a
candidate dies before the election
and that is the big question on many
people's minds right now
we don't have a federal law that
specifies what happens if a candidate
for president dies before the election
in the absence of a federal law saying
if a candidate dies we do x y and z
we have to look to several places to
determine what happens
we look at the rules of the political
parties state law and cases which are
similar but i warn you that this is
largely uncharted territory because
we've never had a presidential candidate
die right before an election in the
modern era and we don't have
any supreme court cases directly on
point so let's first examine what the
political parties have to say about this
issue the democratic national committee
has a clear rule for the situation the
447 members of the dnc
would meet and choose their new nominee
the dnc chair currently tom perez
is required to consult with the
democratic leadership in congress and
with the democratic governors
association
after the consultation the chair
provides a report to the dnc members who
then make the choice presumably in this
case they would pick kamala harris if
joe biden were
incapacitated or other but they're not
required to do so
the republican national committee has
similar rules the rnc has 168 members
three from each state plus three from
six territories
the members would re-vote in a similar
manner as they did at the convention
if those three members of a state
disagree with each other then they each
get to cast one-third of the votes of
that
state and again they might pick mike
pence in this situation but they're not
obligated to put him at the top of the
ticket
as an example consider the 1972 general
election when the democratic party
filled a vacancy because
vice presidential nominee senator thomas
eagleton resigned at the end of july
the democratic national committee met on
august 8th to nominate r
sergeant shriver as the new vice
presidential candidate
so so far so good right i mean the
parties would just decide
who they wanted and the voters would go
vote well
actually no it's way more complicated
than that the parties would still need
to replace the name
of their dead or incapacitated candidate
on each state's ballot
with that of the new candidate the
constitution gives the states the right
to set the time place and manner over
federal elections
this gives states the power to say how a
candidate gets put on the state ballot
the courts have confirmed that the
states have a compelling interest in
finalizing the ballot and establishing
deadlines
so far courts have been reluctant to
find any problem with how the states
finalized their ballots
the states have considerations such as
timely handling of absentee ballots
military ballots
vote tabulation and they're allowed to
administratively run elections without
federal interference
this is why states have deadlines for
when the parties must certify their
candidates for the ballot
and here this is a huge issue because
most ballot access deadlines have
already passed because they were in
august and september
only a few states have deadlines in
october california new hampshire rhode
highland and wisconsin
and a real problem arises when the
candidate dies in october or november
which is too late to get on the ballot
but right before the election
what happens to the vote for the
deceased candidate well we know the
answer when it comes to
electing a member of congress and it's
potentially
instructive for a presidential candidate
there are two main ways of handling this
there's the american rule and the
british rule
the constitution says the house and the
senate each quote shall be the judge of
the elections returns and qualifications
of its own members
so congress gets to decide what happens
to a dead congress person's vote
congress has always followed the
american rule which says that the votes
given to the dead candidate
are not void those votes are considered
valid and if the dead person receives
the most votes this creates a vacancy
in the office that vacancy will be
filled according to the constitution
and vacancies in the senate are filled
in accord with the 17th amendment which
permits governors to temporarily appoint
someone to the senate seat
and here's an example of how that works
in the real world missouri governor mel
carnahan won election to the senate in
missouri in 2000
38 days after he and his son died in a
plane crash under missouri election law
the names of deceased candidates remain
on the ballot if they die so close to
the election that the filing deadline or
the time for political parties to
substitute a candidate has passed
and missouri law expressly follows the
american rule which
means that carnahan's death and the
subsequent victory created a vacancy
carnahan's death created two vacancies
one in the senate and
also one as missouri governor roger
wilson ascended to the acting governor
upon carnahan's death and he announced
that he would appoint gene carnahan
mel's wife
to the senate seat house vacancies are
also handled according to state law but
governors must provide for a special
election rather than appointing someone
on an interim basis
and this is what happened when two
democratic members of the house hail
boggs of louisiana
and nick begich of alaska were killed on
october 16
1972. under louisiana and alaska law it
was too late to replace them on the
ballot
both deceased candidates won their races
and their seats were eventually filled
by a special election
but not everyone likes the rule that
dead candidates can win elections
the minority rule known as the british
rule would give the election to the next
highest vote getter
this means that the person who finished
second would be seated in the house or
senate this rule has not been followed
by either house of congress and some
argue that
the election of a dead person should be
considered a nullity and we should just
have a new election to fill the seat
regardless
the argument for the british rule is
that the senate and house have a right
to judge the qualifications of its
members
and a person who is dead can't be
properly qualified therefore the
election should at least be a nullity
congress has been reluctant to adopt
this british rule because it invalidates
the will of the people in a popular
election and it would arguably conflict
with a lot of state laws which followed
the american rule with their own
precedent for handling vacancies but
this still doesn't tell us precisely
what would happen if a presidential
candidate died in
a federal presidential election when it
was too late for them to be replaced on
the ballots for
all 50 states moreover the death of a
presidential candidate does not create a
vacancy so we need to look at how
presidents are elected so the question
is what happens if a presidential
candidate dies right before the election
when voters cast their votes on november
3rd they're not actually casting votes
for a specific person instead they're
casting votes for a slate of electors
who will be sent to the electoral
college
that makes the presidential election
different from senate or
house election and we can argue until
the cows come home about
whether the electoral college is a good
thing or a bad thing but it's the system
that we have
so now let's assume that the president
dies two days before the election
there's not a time for the courts to
resolve the ballot access problem the
election is happening with his name on
the ballot in
some states and mike pence's name on the
ballot in states that allowed for a
substitution
and the first thing to know is that if
the president passes away under the 25th
amendment then the vice president
becomes president no matter
what because the rules of succession
established by the constitution
and if biden won the election then
there's not really a problem biden would
be sworn in in 2021
and pence would be president until then
but what if joe biden dies and then
subsequently wins
does kamala harris become president and
what if the combined trump's pence
ticket
received 270 electoral votes meaning
that the ticket won the election
does trump get to be sworn in for a new
term well the answer lies with the
electoral college
so each state's electoral votes usually
go to the winner of the state's popular
vote some states allow electors to vote
for anyone they choose about
30 states require the electors to be
bound by the state's popular vote
14 of the 30 states have laws mandating
that the electoral vote be cancelled if
the person goes rogue
this is called being a faithless elector
however some states simply penalize the
elector with a fine or
short jail term but their vote can still
be cast for someone other than the
popular vote winner
few states actually have laws specifying
what electors do if a candidate dies
before the electoral college meets
indiana law says that electors should
switch their votes the political party's
replacement candidate
so if a deceased candidate trump wins
under indiana law
the electoral votes would go to whoever
the republican party replaces him with
which
may be mike pence but it could be
somebody else in contrast michigan law
requires electors to vote for the
winning candidates
who appear on the ballot presumably this
means that they must vote for the vice
presidential candidate on the ballot
the electors may simply cast their votes
for the person the winning political
party has put up
as the replacement candidate or an
elector could believe that they should
cast their vote for the dead candidate
because
state law commands it or for any other
reason an elector could do that
even though there is precedent for
congress disallowing the vote for a
deceased candidate
but what the state parties and electors
have to do in this event is largely
governed by state law and as usual
lawfare has done the hard work and taken
on the herculean effort of compiling
all the law of the states that are
likely to be in play here so if you're
curious about
what the various state laws mandate
during a vacancy definitely check out
law fair
in the 1872 election congress decided
not to count three electoral votes for
presidential candidate horace greeley
who had died after the november election
but before the meeting of the electoral
college
would congress follow that precedent
it's impossible to say
if one party controlled both houses of
congress then it'd be easier for them to
invalidate the electoral votes of the
deceased candidate
but the electoral college does not vote
until december 14th of this year
over a month after the election if a
candidate dies between the election and
the electoral college voting
the process is the same that i talked
about before the party seeks a
replacement candidate and the party
would probably expect their electors to
still vote for their new candidate
but they're not necessarily required to
do so it depends on the state law
and they could vote for another member
of their party or even a third party
candidate if they wanted to
and then of course it gets even more
complicated if no candidate can be
certified to have 270 electoral college
votes
under the 12th amendment which we'll
talk about in just a second
so then there's a question of what if a
president-elect dies after the electoral
college meets but before being
inaugurated
congress will count the electoral
college votes on january 6 2021.
they must then certify that vote and if
a winning candidate were to die between
december 15th
after the electors have voted but before
january 6th
things start to get pretty messy there
isn't a federal law that says whether
the electoral votes of the diseased
candidate also count for the vice
president
the constitution's 20th amendment says
the vice president-elect becomes
president if the president-elect dies
before inauguration day
but it also provides that if the
president has not qualified by january
20th
then the vice president-elect serves as
acting president until a president
qualifies
the vice president-elect who is
subsequently inaugurated as
president would then nominate a vice
president under provisions in section 2
of the 25th amendment
but that might not actually resolve the
problem here does a candidate formally
become the president-elect after winning
the electoral college vote or
only after congress certifies the vote
this is a question that has remained
unanswered
however in the 1932 house committee
report accompanying the 20th amendment
it actually explains that the authors of
the amendment felt that the counting of
the votes does not matter
when determining if a person is
president-elect quote
it will be noted that the committee uses
the term president-elect in its
generally accepted sense as
meaning the person who has received the
majority of electoral votes or the
person who has been chosen by the house
of representatives in the event that the
election is thrown into the house
it is immaterial whether or not the
votes have been counted
for the person becomes the
president-elect as soon as the votes are
cast this still isn't the clean
resolution that we were probably hoping
for in a crazy hypothetical like this
if congress says it cannot certify the
count for a dead candidate for whatever
reason the congress chooses
then the house of representatives picks
the president according to the 12th
amendment
under the 12th amendment if no candidate
for president receives a majority of the
electoral college votes
then the house gets to decide and the
house must choose from the top three
vote-getters but this means that in a
two-horse race such as what we have this
year
then effectively the living candidate
would then become president but as you
can imagine this whole process
would be insanely political and
basically chaos
and it's not entirely clear but if the
president-elect were to die after
congress has certified the electoral
college vote on january 6th
then the most likely scenario is that
the rules of succession would apply
meaning the vice president-elect would
then become president but this whole
situation sounds like a recipe for
absolute chaos and i think i speak for
most americans when i say that
hopefully this is a normal election
between two healthy individuals and the
winner wins
fair and square but at the end of the
day if things do go pear-shaped it's
basically a matter of state law but
those laws only come into play if the
election is close
so let's make this election a blowout
and avoid another bush versus gore
so call your friends and family and tell
them to vote absentee or
in person if they can and the best way
to make that call is with ting mobile
ting provides great lte 5g coverage
because it partners with the biggest
carrier so you get the benefit of three
massive networks
because ting mobile is a different kind
of mobile provider with ting you only
pay for your actual data and services
that you use at the end of the month
and because you're only paying for what
you actually use ting customers pay on
average just 23 dollars per month for
one device
and with ting you can use almost any
cell phone including the newest iphones
and google pixel phones and you can use
the same phone number you're using right
now there's no contract overage fees or
any other carrier tricks
you just pay a fair price for the talk
text and data that you use up
every month and ting has award-winning
customer service
because they don't have any
brick-and-mortar stores not that any of
us are going to brick and mortar stores
these days they pour all of their
resources into their phones and online
support
and if you have any issues you can give
them a call and you'll immediately talk
to a real human being
with ting especially if you're around
wi-fi all the time which of course most
of us
are since a lot of us are working from
home you'll end up paying way less than
you do now because you're not
actually using cell servers you're using
the wi-fi coverage
of course some people should pay 200 a
month for unlimited data if they're
nowhere near their homes
but if you're surrounded by wi-fi all
day long then you might be paying
hundreds of dollars more for your cell
phone
completely unnecessarily and ting gives
you the option to pay only for what you
use
so if you go to legaleagle.ting.com you
can use your last bill to compare just
how much you would save
and legal eagles will get a 25 credit by
going to legaleagle.ting.com
and that could cover your entire first
month of service and since there are no
contracts you can try it for a month no
strings attached
again all you have to do is click on the
link in the description or go to
legaleagle.ting.com
and get a 25 credit for whatever service
you want plus clicking on that link
really helps out this channel so do you
agree with my analysis leave your
objections in the comments
and check out this playlist over here
with my coverage of all the crazy things
that are happening
right before the election because it's
2020 and the law is crazy so
click on this playlist and i'll see you
in court